réveille-toi [ __ ] de merde rien à
[ __ ] de ta dépression rien à [ __ ] de
tes excuses rien à [ __ ] de ton petit
coeur brisé rien à [ __ ] de ta pression
monte a rien à [ __ ] de ta feignant
disent rien à [ __ ] de tes doutes
arrête d'être une mère d'être une
personne sans aucune motivation
arrête de gaspiller ta vie lève toi
maintenant tout de suite voilà alors bon
c'est extrêmement violent oui ah ben oui
oui oui c'est très bien il a fait un
petit magnéto pour s'excuser une petite
vidéo on va la regarder et on en parlait
juste après hier j'ai fait un tick tock
motivation pour encourager toutes les
personnes qui se sentent mal dans leur
peau à aller de l'avant mon but était
aussi de motiver les personnes victimes
de dépression et malheureusement tout le
monde n'a pas bien compris comme ça la
dépression est une vraie maladie c'est
difficile de s'en sortir mais il existe
des solutions et c'est vraiment ce que
je voulais montrer à travers le tictoc
donc je tiens à m'excuser pour les
personnes qui ont mal interprété mon
type tôt si je suis sur terre c'est pour
motiver les gens à faire du sport et à
prendre soin de vous commencez à me
connaître à force donc un gros courage
et soutien à toutes les personnes
victimes de dépression on y
voit là son père alors salle alors
daniel moreau sable a choqué à non non
non ça m'a pas gentil ça passe à l
apache qui se tiendra à non non
non ça m'étonne non et oui je sais je
sais bien parce que j'ai eu une
dépression une vraie dépression et c'est
une vraie maladie et c'est ça qui ont
choqué a choqué mais tout le monde
emploie le mot dépression et je trouve
qu'il a fait d'un bad buzz un truc super
sait qu'il a fait une vidéo avec une psy
qui a expliqué que oui c'était une vraie
maladie mais lui il a dans son esprit
c'était juste un petit coup de déprime à
les réveille toi tape du pied tu vas
aller mieux donc moi franchement je lui
accorde des circonstances atténuantes
ferait du tort mais ça c'est le côté je
suis d'accord avec daniel en fait c'est
toujours le mot on emploie toujours ce
mot à la tv ou les souvenirs des prêts
sauce bon voilà c'est vrai que il a
peut-être pas mesuré d'ailleurs il l'a
dit il a rattrapé l'histoire après coup
le l'impact que ça pouvait avoir sur
effectivement les gens qui sont
véritablement dépressif qui souffrent de
cette maladie mais je trouve que il a
une espèce de volonté de bouger en tout
cas les jeunes de les motiver et il fait
un truc un peu esprit bout de came quoi
une formation américaine soit voilà donc
c'est ça donc c'est aller et bouge toi
ma chance et ça c'est le boulot comme
celle-là c'est l'armée en fête
américaine c'est comme ça bon c'est son
truc c'est son fer de lance c'est sa
manière de travailler de se reconnaître
c'est le problème c'est que les gens qui
l'ont vu cette vidéo ils n'ont pas été
plus loin que le bout de leur nez parce
que c'est exactement ça les gens c'est
tu le sais bungie taux qui va la salle
on écoute souvent des trucs comme ça
dans l'oreille pour se motiver ou sait
des choses à six mois je sais qu'une
merde
mais le problème c'est que les gens se
sont arrêtés là dessus et ça a été
interprété comme ça c'est comme en quart
la semaine dernière j'ai dit que les
français étaient les fennecs oui on crée
donc créé des feignants et à les payer à
rien faire et les gens ils s'arrêtent
aux premiers mots et là ils ont fait
pareil alors que c'est simplement
booster les gens quoi jean pascal est
aussi ceux qui sont pas bien dans leur
bulle au delà de la borne t mont-garin
mais c'est le jeu
mais moi je suis vraiment choqué
honnêtement que prenait toujours à dire
la dépression la dépression mais il faut
qu'il faut comprendre qu'il ya un 1 36
sur cinq est touché par la dépression 3%
des dépressifs se suicident chaque année
moi même je vais vous le dire je suis
inquiet je suis sous antidépresseurs
depuis six mois et quand j'entends ça
honnêtement je vais lui [ __ ] une tarte
si je peux mais je n'ai pas pouvoir de
toute
façon y'a pas que prennent des risques
mais il faut arrêter parce que c'est
toujours pareil les gens un tempo l'air
maintenant la bipolarité c'est une
maladie at anorexique mais non
l'anorexie une maladie at et dépressif
la dépression une maladie mais il faut
arrêter de toujours prendre ces termes
comme si c'étaient pas des malades il ya
des gens derrière qui entendent ça et
quand ils ont entendu quelqu'un dire
comme ça quelqu'un d'aussi influent dit
rien à [ __ ] de ta dépression il ya des
dépressifs qui attendent ça il ya des
dépressifs qui se voyait stigmatiser qui
se voyaient comme des mets de leur
gueule et ils n'ont pas besoin de ça
pour un magnifique essai de pas les
dépressifs et des tentations sera pas du
tout mais des mois peut-être mais
peut-être
suis-je suite foncièrement choqué
d'autant que c'est pas du tout l'une de
ses premières sorties polémiques je
pense que quand on a lu millions
d'abonnés on a un engagement envers
senna une responsabilité envers ses huit
millions d'abonnés thibault à une chute
sa petite copine jusqu'au port il aime
bien faire des petites sorties de route
comme as faut le savoir et il est et
donc il connaît quand même un peu
straumann l'enferment de stromae les
professionnels de la santé estime que
cette chanson à sauver des vies il ya eu
+ 37 % de prise de rendez vous chez les
psychiatres et les psychologues le 31 14
qui est la ligne justement pour quand on
a un problème la ligne à contacter le
standard a littéralement explosé parce
qu'il ya plein de personnes justement
qu'ils se sentaient stigmatisé le fait
d'être dépressif isoz est pas en parler
et bacs depuis ils se sentent libérés
grâce à straumann et quand tu es un
connard qui arrive à être devant et qui
dit anne est claire
rien à [ __ ] de ta dépression jeu a
très envie je vous dis entendu je
comprends que ça oui c'est choquant en
détention qu'il adore ces mecs et moi je
vais lui supprimer sa chaîne youtube ça
m'a fait goûter à l'or et je comprends
les deux versions à mépriser ou de la
dépression je pense qu'il ya
effectivement plusieurs step il ya soit
le maoût soit vraiment la maladie mais
dans les deux cas le sport peut m'aider
à soulager et à se sentir bien parce que
quand on fait du sport tu vas descendre
la piste face aux pluies en fait ce
qu'ils devaient expliquer c'est que même
ce n'est pas bien même mais même si tu
as la dépression va courir va faire
d'exercice ça me fera du bien d'enfin
bien sûr qu'il y en a rien à [ __ ]
c'est trop violent mais rien n'a de sens
bien avec moi bien faire du sport mais
la piscine la sauver brio
franchement je trouve que bien sûr ça
peut choquer cet aspect hors de son
contexte mais profite si le film moi non
mais vraiment la natation c'est
moi j'avais franchement je ne lui en
veux pas on va avancer les choses de
bien après avec le psy donc